The truth is we don't know if North
Korea has the ability to hit the United
States with an intercontinental
ballistic missile. If we wanted to shoot
it down, the only way we could be
reasonably certain of doing so is to get
in what we call the "boost phase". That's
what's lifting off from North Korea. It's
probably impossible for us, at this point,
to have a certainty of getting it when
it's coming down in the "terminal phase".
Also, if we did that, we would forfeit the
opportunity to gather intelligence on
just how advanced the missile program is.
There's also no assurance that they'd be
shooting it toward us, but they could be
shooting it towards other areas in the
Pacific, or Asia. What we should
probably do is follow it this time,
gather as much intelligence as we can,
see whether the program is successful,
and also see where they sent it. If they
do send it towards us, we should make
clear that US policy in the future is
to shoot down a North Korean
ballistic missile during the boost phase,
regardless of whether it is loaded
with a nuclear warhead or whether it is
aimed towards us.
That's the only way to make sure that
North Korea knows were serious.
To learn more about my take on the risks
threatening Asia's future peace and
prosperity, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.